hey cousin heard you're having money
problems no you didn't listen I got the
answer you declare bankruptcy all your
problems go away
Creed Bratton has never declared
bankruptcy when creed bratton gets in
trouble he transfers his debt to William
Charles Neider how would that help Creed
and monopoly you go bankrupt you lose
you don't go by monopoly man that game
is nuts nobody just picks up
get-out-of-jail-free cards those things
cost thousands that is a good point
bankruptcy Michael is nature's do-over
it's a fresh start it's a clean slate
like the witness protection program
exotically I've always wanted to be in
the witness protection program fresh
start no debts no baggage Bart I got my
name picked out Lord Rupert Everton I
made a shipping merchant who raises
fancy dogs that's the life I declare
bankruptcy
hey I just wanted you to know that you
can't just say the word bankruptcy and
expect anything to happen I didn't say
it I declared it still that's it's not
anything this is a lot of credit card
debt yeah you know Janice my credit
cards and she's using them as if I made
of money
she thinks I'm a human ATM machine okay
$125 Amazon Oh best in the Muppet Show
on DVD classic $1200 what's a core
blaster extreme that is by far the best
way to strengthen your core this machine
you sit on a stabilizer ball you put
your feet into the power stirrups you
reach up and you grab onto the super rod
and you twist and you twist twist
it strengthens your entire core your
back core your arm core your the Marine
Corps actually uses it I think that's
what however they got core what should
we do tonight I don't know it was finger
we'll just order some pizza you watch me
play xbox and then I can watch you make
some prank phone calls we get hammered
make you do that every night it's
because repetition is the key to a good
marriage let's do something weird come
on it could be the last night Arthur we
can do something off my bucket list
you have a bucket list kept swinging
touchdown at the Super Bowl make the
most amazing grilled-cheese sandwich
ever win the lottery ride a unicycle
invent something I'd like to remake the
movie Kazaam which the kilo Neil where
he plays a genie and I'd like to get it
right go skydiving outrun a hippo fly
first class on a plane when people are
walking by be like this all right well
this is what we're doing tonight wait
which one this one 800 900 1000 how much
is left in the bank account 18 dollars
and four cents whoa still a lot left
over okay you wanted to hold $1,000 cash
in your hands
that's super disappointing 998 999 1000
yes now this is what I imagined I just
handed it to you
nickels I want Nikolas a billion nickels
where does paper come from trees and
where do trees grow for soil right we
have in front of you here seven
different types of Pennsylvania topsoil
now what would you say is the most
important element in the production of
above-ground leafy growth probably
phosphorus right wrong its nitrogen
absorb this information good now let us
discuss precipitation Stanley when
rainfall occurs does it usually fall in
a liquid solid or gaseous state look
wooden very good you've earned one
Schrute buck I don't want it then you
have been deducted 50 Schrute bucks make
it 100 don't you want to earn Schrute
bucks no in fact I'll give you a billion
Stanley nickels if you never talk to me
again what's the ratio of Stanley
nickels to Schrute bucks the same as the
ratio of unicorns and leprechauns okay
that's it what are you doing I'm
punishing them let's listen - Dwight's
presentation what what are you waiting
for lid so we need to find proof of
every tax deduction I've taken in the
last five years most of these aren't
even receipts this one says I bought
supplies 2007 you won't find any bank
statements either
I've heavily invested in gold which I've
buried in several different locations
around quani or have I it's this some
kind of lame drug deal that is a
gentlemen's agreement I made that man a
dining room table and exchange for 60
feet of copper pipe and a half pig
well looks like what you have some
actual receipts here same amount every
month 140 bucks what's this every 30
days i buy shotgun shells of cigarettes
and send them home to my mom sweetie
your mom sounds kick-ass my first
ex-wife's name is Tammy my second
ex-wife's name is Tammy my mom's name is
Tamara she goes by Tammy I call about a
problem with you did somebody call Hank
Hank thank god you're here the office is
at a crossroads so there's no security
problem
you know I hustled up the stairs yes I
need your sage advice and everyone
whatever Hank decides that is the
decision that will resolve this issue
yeah take as many as you want thank you
thank you you know it's nice and warm up
here yes well what are we talking about
okay well we have a surplus imagine that
your parents give you money for a
lemonade stand I know what a surplus is
okay good good well here's the thing
some people want to use the surplus to
buy a new copier other people are
complaining about the chairs without the
copier it is yes
mmm-hmm what no just thinking let me see
a chair okay
you can try mine oh there we go hmm
not much lumbar support no everyone bear
in mind once again that whatever Hank
says goes he is an impartial third party
on the one hand this copier is very oh
you should see some of the new copiers
they have you would not believe what
they do sound of the copier well let me
finish alright yes now the chairs the
chairs are very weak very weak tears I
could not sit all day in this chair well
what should I do I'm gonna see the
copier again alright get out get out
hello so it looks like we gende up with
about five thousand apiece stop we got
five g's each it's amazing you started
out with four hundred and fifty thousand
entertainment720 is dead it's up in
company heaven along with pets.com
Blockbuster and Ask Jeeves
my company is no better than a company
where you ask a fake Butler to Google
things for you so what's the next time
you Davidson I say we invest our 10
large and then I accidentally get run
over by a city bus and we start our own
hip-hop label we had this place for one
more night right we rowdy tomorrow noon
what if we took every dime we had left
through one last party and added the
essence of everything we wanted the
company to be a party for the end of the
world you had me at every time we have
left because I'm in like Laura Flynn
Boyle from the practice a little lizard
[Music]
DJ puts us in the buildin pit
announcement donnatella t-mobile three
words for you
treat yo so treat yourself 2011 once a
year Donna and I spend a day treating
ourselves when we treat ourselves to
clothes
treat yourself fragrances treat yourself
massages tricky stuff mimosa
treat yourself fine leather goods treat
yourself it's the best day of the year
the best day of year
you